this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah let's get started uh welcome
everyone to episode six of the Cornell
Turf Show season four right we've been
doing this our fourth year now
um our guest today is Dr Aaron Patton
from Purdue uh a Purdue theme Here Frank
we had uh kale Bigelow on a couple weeks
ago and now we're getting Aaron on here
uh looking just looking Aaron's uh
Recent research up Frank we've got a lot
of interesting things Aaron's been
working on so I don't know what we'll
get to today but uh will surely be an
interesting conversation uh Frank as
always I'll pass it over to you and you
can get us started today with some of
your most recent thoughts let's go here
I think I got I think I
listen this is getting to be my uh
favorite thing of all the things that I
do and I'm really happy to have
wonderful professionals that are willing
to give their time but Carl you know as
we always get started uh we you know we
try to get people thinking about things
other than Turf well there's obviously
Masters if you're in a golf business but
if you're in the baseball business which
I love baseball
um the pace of these games is making me
very happy I don't need to watch people
adjust their equipment for 35 minutes to
get them to appreciate uh you know
watching a baseball game so Carl I want
to start out by saying you know this has
been a big advancement uh and actually a
big change in thinking uh about the way
we think about baseball and I know
you've got something that we don't
intuitively think about uh when we're
thinking about sports and and that is
your rant for today on rolling hmm yeah
so so Frank we talk a lot about rolling
in in the in the a golf course since
right on putting greens and there's even
some research on Fairway rolling
obviously at the elite level whether
we're watching The Masters or any other
PGA Tour Tournament right those greens
are getting rolled quite often and we
understand the the benefits of that in a
golf course sense uh I was sort of
interested hey you know what sort of
research is there in the sports field
sense and on our state Sports field
website we talk a little bit about
rolling you know the benefits there
obviously you smooth the surface you
make it more even so you get better ball
roll more predictability the coaches and
the athletes love that you can firm up a
surface that's maybe a little bit too
wet and of course the speed right and
that's the thing the coaches will always
talk about hey I want to see that ball
rolling out uh nice and true but we also
make a a nod too that you have to sort
of do this thoughtfully right especially
in the saturated soil environment right
avoid rolling uh that that might uh you
know disrupt the soil structure but I
sort of looked up you know turf grass
information file is a great thing for
people to to look up there's a bunch of
abstract right these aren't things that
that maybe make it all the way to being
published but there's some really cool
data in listening to these abstracts so
this is one on lightweight rolling from
Michigan State of course Tom Nikolai is
involved uh in this basically there were
three treatments in our Athletic Field
uh no rolling three times per week and
five times per week so that five times
per week is probably a pretty high rate
of rolling for for those in the athletic
fields predictably right you see
increases in the ball roll distance just
like on a putting green we have a stiff
meter there's a device where you roll a
ball off see how far it travels they saw
significant increases in that five times
per week rolling frequency of the
increased ball roll distance somewhere
you know it depends on the rating day a
meter to a meter and a half right five
or six feet at the most maybe not so
much of the three times rolling
frequency so interesting that you really
need to roll a lot to get those benefits
a similar thing you saw with the
firmness which I didn't show the data on
here but there's these other benefits
that you might get out of rolling
athletic fields broadleaf weed counts so
you can see here for those watching on
the left you could see a higher number
of broadleaf weeds per plot then the the
either of the Rolling treatments they
didn't come up with statistical
significance on this uh and maybe that's
that's maybe another rant for me Frank
is uh statistical significance versus
practical significance right does that
make a difference so they weren't really
able to say hey there was a statistical
decrease in broadleaf weeds due to
Rolling but Frank you and I have seen
this out in the field and we've done
some testing on our turf plots where
rolling absolutely sort of gets the
weeds out of there and there's this
beautiful picture I took I think it's
two aprils ago now the botanic gardens
um the botanic garden Visitor Center at
Cornell and you can see where all the
vehicles Drive there's no dandelions
right and you can see in the peripheral
areas where there's no vehicle traffic
lots of dandelions Frank you saw this
with Chris citgo's work with crabgrass
controlling crabgrass with High rolling
frequencies out of the vineyard we've
seen it at our Bluegrass Lane plots
where we rolled a fairway constantly and
a year after uh we even saw uh no
crabgrass in those plots so you know
maybe there's a lot of other stuff that
we get out of rolling in athletic fields
and and when they when they were making
their conclusions here in this study
they didn't see any detrimental effects
so I think as long as as we avoid the
real saturated conditions you know I'm a
fan of rolling more uh whether it's golf
courses or or Sports Fields I I like the
idea of rolling really as much as you
can because it's hard to push it to the
Limit where I think you see maybe some
of those traffic or compaction issues
right okay Carl this is brilliant
because of all the things we could chat
with Aaron about with regard to sports
fields and the many things he uh gets
involved with this is one that didn't
come to mind to me but Aaron I'd love to
get your two cents on this as Carl said
we see this consistently I've also seen
it with Clover and ground ivy and other
plants now I know siroccan's done some
traffic tolerance things on this but
there is a fine line you know obviously
we will we sort of said a thick dense
Turf keeps the weeds out I'll say
somebody sometimes gets a little thin
itself but the weeds still don't grow so
I'd love to hear your speculation on
this because of the many things we're
going to get through that you had
studied this does not appear to be one
that you have studied yet or if you have
I haven't found it yet what do you think
yeah so Tom uh Nikolai and I have talked
about this topic and and even
considering consider doing some research
on it in the past
um yeah certainly just weeds are not as
traffic tolerant as Turf and you had
mentioned some work out of Tennessee
that shows that
um and obviously just pictures like this
uh demonstrate that now we have to be
careful that we're we're looking I I
don't doubt your findings but we have to
be careful there's not just maybe some
delayed flowering caused by traffic or
some other thing right so we'd have to
obviously go on site and look look down
on the ground and make sure we don't
just find dandelions that are further
further back developmentally but I I
agree that the grasses are more traffic
tolerant than the weeds and so having a
little traffic or a little rolling can
help get rid of them I guess what's
um
what's uh maybe stop me from doing
research on on it in the past is just a
practicality of adding rolling as a
management practice from a labor
standpoint uh just to accomplish some
weed control
um but we know that there are certain
sites where they can't use herbicides
but maybe they do have uh you know
enough Labor budget that they could
Implement other cultural practices so so
this could be something that they could
do and so what we would have to do is
then figure out okay well how often
would I actually have to roll these
sites uh to get that we control them
after and Carl referenced you know one
one study that had attempted to answer
some of those questions so
so because because Watson uh in the 50s
uh had something in the green section
record where he looked at compaction
effects on crabgrass germination because
as Carl mentioned Aaron we've actually
seen some persistent uh crabgrass
suppression in the tire tracks a year or
two year and two years after we
initially imposed the treatment and the
turf is really at uh full cover but uh
and I haven't looked at the soils and
played around but there was this
suggestion that potentially compacted
soils are not conducive to germinating
which also is a bit counter-intuitive
because I always thought that's where I
saw Goose Grass more and maybe Goose
grass is more tolerant of compacted
soils than crabgrass but I think any
study of this I thought you were going
to say the practicality of actually
studying the weed seed bank that's got
its own problems in addition to the
practicality to adding rolling now we
had uh doctor ask you on yesterday it's
weed science week here on the turf show
and uh he's doing that crazy stuff with
the heating and the cooling and then he
puts a plate or a block on it right some
form of pressure is there something in
weed science I'm not familiar with with
pressure that is uh adding to the stress
on a plant because I'm thinking that's
obviously what rolling is doing too the
weight and pressure on the plant and
he's always combining it with uh you
know either a cryogenic treatment or a
thermal treatment uh when he does it I'm
just wondering what you guys what if
there's anything about you know pressing
on a weed or just just straight up
traffic columns
um yeah I'm not sure I mean certainly
there's something going on there that
you know these other plants are just
less traffic tolerant than the grasses
right so there's something to their Leaf
architecture or their structural
components that are different that's not
allowing them to yeah uh uh to be as as
elastic or to be as rigid or to to be
able to recover maybe as well uh you
know from that damage
um I gotta think that having that uh
that that Crown right down there near
the soil surface is is very helpful for
these Turf grasses to to handle that
traffic tolerance and and many of our
weeds may not have uh you may have that
meristem up a little bit higher or maybe
damaged
um you know by the traffic more so than
the crown of the turf grass plant is but
that would certainly be something that
that would need some more study this is
great because Tom needs something to do
in retirement
all right so listen let me just do a
little weather here and it looks like
you know it's weird we have these warm
Winters and we expect a season like it
teased us back in late February and and
honestly now we'd say it's it's 10 days
behind normal
uh interestingly uh normal is the
30-year normal in almost 20 days behind
where we were even last year it just
seems like these Springs are having a
harder and harder time uh so we're
really developing even after a mild
winter I think that's very interesting
when we think about how our systems
develop and we have to time certain
things now now the national phonology
Network right another sort of a you know
observational data citizen science stuff
people taking data like this is saying
you know we're really leaping out uh
well ahead of normal spring looks like
it's close to 15 to 20 days early in
some parts of the Northeast which I find
really interesting it's sort of two ways
of looking at it how are the plants
responding and what is the data from a
heat accumulation perspective uh telling
us now looking at soils you know I did
this yesterday we're sort of into the
50s in the New York City metro area
still in the 40s North but this is going
to change pretty rapidly it's been wet
to the west and dry to the east which
means in the East the soils are really
going to start warming because we are
pretty locked in now based on our
climate Center predictions for the next
couple of weeks into a reliably above
normal sometimes 10 to 12 degrees above
normal and a reliably dry period as a
high pressure front sits over us and
locks in and again we talk about how
this happens as a signal of climate
change because as the gradient changes
from the cool to the warmth of the of
the middle right the poles used to be
really cold and there was a nice
gradient all the way down to the middle
of the Earth and now that gradient has
changed and it gets these patterns
locked and the atmospheric River out
west is of course uh another example of
that now when it gets to a weed
conversation we think I've been thinking
about this in a number of ways because
obviously the flowering component has a
a big issue from a wrist perspective
because we got a lot of of people in our
industry professionals regularly
applying materials into the uh regularly
applying materials into the landscape so
we're trying to pay more attention to
this Carl's going to be maybe doing some
risk models on when these things are
flowering when the risk is greatest ways
of minimizing that risk if you're going
to put an herbicide out and Aaron we've
been using the one developed prior to
your arrival which is quite a quite a
number of years back when Zach and Clark
were looking at this Growing Degree day
model for treating it in the spring
we've sort of adopted it as a good
trigger point uh for people but you can
see in the coming week we're still not
that far along uh based on this model
we're still it's bare the ideal time for
both the amine and the Ester which
typically gets used earlier is still
barely in the southern part of the
region so there's it could likely change
quickly as we get warmer uh this could
start coming but at least not for
another week will we be anywhere near
this application all right so we're
talking about one of the things we're
talking about is weeds uh in athletic
fields which is its own particular
talents particularly in school districts
Aaron where you know you don't have
herbicides but before we get to that big
congrats on becoming a fellow right uh
as a you know I I know you've been a
weed scientist uh for a long time uh but
getting a fellow in the Agronomy Society
congratulations on that that happened in
2021 but I I also wanted to call out I
was looking at your faculty page and you
list a couple of the things you're
working on and one of them is low input
Turf and one of your focal points here
and the third thing and I thought my
colleague Dr skimenti here would
appreciate this comment that you called
it Urban grasslands
right this is a term we are using more
frequently and I you know I want to get
it on the air here that it's somebody
other than us calling it Urban
grasslands uh was there any particular
reason uh why you've adopted that
because obviously when you look at Turf
in the malesi paper you only find it
primarily in urban areas so I don't know
why we're afraid to call it this Turf
now means synthetic stuff to people let
me get your comments on Urban grasslands
before we move forward
well yeah so there's a there's a couple
a couple of ways we can go on that
conversation so from from an urban
grassland standpoint I guess I adopted
that term you know several years ago
because
um mainly I guess because of the biases
of some people against Turf grasses
and so I wanted to help I guess to help
them understand you know that uh you
know we're we're just studying
grasslands used in urban areas you know
and so uh to uh we all know there's a
lot of benefits to manage Turfgrass
systems and you know if we do some
things wrong there can be some some uh
some harm that could come to the
environment but when we're doing things
the correctly the way we recommend and
so on there's a lot of benefits uh
brought to these uh urban communities
and so on so I just wanted to kind of
highlight that with that terminology
perfect great and yes the term Turf has
been hijacked and that's right that
happened to me just uh you know just a
few weeks ago when I was taking a ride
from the car dealership who was working
on my car to campus and I was in a
conversation with somebody and it wasn't
until nine minutes in the conversation
that I realized that they thought I
studied plastic fibers you know and so
no I study growing plants real plants
you know and so we talked a little bit
about that your terminology but yeah all
right great well listen
um I also want to give you a big shout
out for your leadership on that original
written publication that now is
resourced by the Wisconsin guys here
just a shout out to everybody and this
includes I think Jenny gown if and got
involved it includes products for New
York and the qualifications uh for New
York so this is a a great resource for
our folks when they're uh thinking about
applying and deciding now you click on
Weeds and you pick your weed and you can
determine uh what you want to do for
control and Aaron I want to start our
conversation for the next 10 minutes or
so on uh annual Bluegrass poet trivialis
and what was it polar palustrous foul
Bluegrass how long were you stumped
before you came to this the
identification of foul Bluegrass just
two minutes how long did it take you to
figure it out
uh it probably took uh you know I don't
know maybe a day or so of looking at
some different samples
um you know what we'll see sometimes and
you probably see this even uh you know
in New York is right you'll find grasses
that don't typically grow in our area
but maybe they came in from seed from
Oregon or Washington or somewhere else
and that's how uh these grasses that we
rarely see maybe pop up from time to
time or sometimes it's more of a
woodland species that particularly in
early spring when they're you know the
trees haven't leafed out yet uh then we
we see these plants growing in a lawn so
yeah lots of different Polo species out
there we normally just deal with a
handful of them but yeah that was one
that I was seeing a lot last spring well
one of the things that has been
happening more and more you know if we
want people to have natural grass
surfaces and maybe having asynthetic
surfaces but more natural grass surfaces
and they want some high performance on
it which more and more schools are going
to want and they're going to start
hiring really good sports turf managers
that are going to roll full fields and
test fields and do things right
um they're going to want to use uh
herbicides in some cases now on K-12
they're not going to be able to do this
uh without an exception but we have a
lot of people who manage Sports Fields
outside of that who listen and watch and
obviously I want to talk a little bit
about your work with mesotrione and
carbosone is is that exonerate
correct that is exonerate okay so you
were involved with Matt uh in publishing
this thing so this particular paper or
you know mesotrione I understand a
little bit you can use it seating but
overall is one of the challenge this is
really what I want to chat with you
about
let's start with Daniel Bluegrass is it
reasonable to have both a herbicide
program for annual Bluegrass on Sports
fields and an overseeding program that
we know we often need routinely on
heavily used Fields so I'm basically
asking how do you put together an
effective herbicide program balancing
with an overseeding program in a cool
Season Market
yeah well as you know anytime we develop
a program to control annual Bluegrass it
gets extremely complex very quickly
because there's so many factors at play
so if we wanted to develop a program
where we wanted to seed and be able to
use herbicides then uh we really have to
first start with you know what dates
were we planning on seeding right were
we were just planning on doing a fall
seating
um uh or were we planning on doing a
spring seating is our seating a dormant
seating which really isn't coming up to
the spring you know and so we really
have to start to think about what
seating dates based on your sport and
the use of those fields and when you can
actually get out there and be able to
see those areas what are those dates
going to be and then from that then we
could build herbicide programs around
those application dates because some of
these products are going to be fall
products some are going to be more
spring products just based on what time
of year they typically work best and so
I would start with the seating because
it's we need grass on our athletic
fields right so we're going to start
there and then from there let's develop
a herbicide program that's not going to
then harm those new seedlings or the
existing grasses that we have growing
there so so then that would preclude any
routine overseeding right in some cases
some people will do that routine
overseeding of the high wear areas we've
had a lot of uptake of that particular
strategy here in the Northeast
particularly getting rye grass into high
traffic areas really high rates on a
routine basis so that would preclude it
but isn't as a try on a viable product
to use through that process obviously
it's going to allow some germination and
give some post control and a little bit
of pre I know it's not everybody's
favorite but it has that and maybe the
same is true with pylex are they
interchangeable that way uh Aaron let's
talk about using herbicides that we can
actually keep seeding with yeah so one
thing I'll I'll mention because you as
you've already said right we're pretty
site-specific with these athletic fields
where we're coming in and seating these
high wear areas yeah so like for
football obviously that's going to be
between the hashes for soccer that's
going to be in front of the goal Mouse
so there's no reason we can't develop a
a herbicide program
um for the areas we're not overseeding
if like in soccer the areas that we're
routinely seating is a very tiny part of
the field so we have to keep that in
mind also
um pilex and tenacity are very different
on POA annual the pylex is not really
going to provide any annual Bluegrass
control
um whereas the tenacity can but the the
the control is somewhat inconsistent so
but we do know that tenacity is a very
useful herbicide to use
um at the time of seeding to keep those
weeds from coming up and competing with
that new grass seed we just put out so
absolutely I think tenacity would be
something you might use on athletic
fields when you're seating and when you
know that there's going to be some weed
germination you know the next two or
three weeks following that seating based
on the time of year and it may or may
not provide annual Bluegrass control
based on the time of year so it's very
interesting I was just out in the
Pacific Northwest uh Aaron and they're
starting to use sithoxin to them for
Selective rye grass control and POA
annual yeah I use that on my research
Farm to kill big grass and my polar bent
grass putting green you know so that's
exactly right yeah so cess oxygen uh can
be used very all the um the group one
herbicides so claim extra Seth oxydine
which is segment
um and uh one fusillade
and what about manuscript is that
fusillade is no manuscript is a
different AI same mode of action I have
not tried that on poor annual but like
uh but that one is uh actually uh just
this year is getting some poor annual
added to the label because the European
labels with that ingredient have had uh
fine Fescue and annual Bluegrass uh
previously and so now since on their U.S
manuscript product are adding uh annual
Bluegrass and fine Fescue to that label
well you know this this is a real Niche
conversation right I mean there's a lot
of weeds that we worry about but but
this is pretty much I I think really the
the toughest one and one of the problems
with it is with its shallow rooted
nature uh it tends to not provide good
rooting if it's in a Bluegrass field of
some sort well poetry and an annual
Bluegrass and so far we you know we've
had this problem on our division one
soccer field here at Cornell uh and it's
expanded dramatically but we have not
seen any increased dividend yet uh
associated with so listen I want to
change gears because I actually reviewed
this paper when you submitted it uh with
uh Ross and are you having withdrawals
now that Ross is gone this guy has been
a factory I love this kid yeah I'm still
having Ross withdrawals yeah imagine so
you did a real this is about to happen
in our turf grass stands Aaron I was
very interested in this now you know I
don't I I think we I got to be careful
right the scalping word always makes me
a little uneasy because of the history
of that and I actually brought that up
in the review of the pay paper that
maybe we should find a different word
and maybe we will at some point but I
think everybody knows what we're talking
about here what we're talking about is
historically in the Northeast and I'm
apparently out in in uh where you are
too rye grass will begin to produce a
flowering stalk that lingers and it'll
do it under traditional mowing Heights
um I'm not entirely sure I know exactly
the environmental conditions under which
it does it you're probably going to
inform me a little bit on that but it is
a persistent problem particularly with
rye grass if you get dry at a certain
time it will literally sit there for six
eight weeks uh and and and give this
brown Haze appearance this stemi-ratty
appearance uh to the turf grass stand
now I read this paper and I was thinking
about what kind of a graph am I going to
show and I figure I'm not going to show
any of those graphs because they're very
noisy graphs it took me a long time to
review this so I want to see if you can
give it to me in a very slow elevator a
ride a summary of If you have this rye
grass steminist problem historically in
your Turf situation is there a
fertilizer and close mowing or scalping
program that will reduce this in your
ryegrass stand
yeah so so just in general most plants
that when they flower they're gonna uh
temperature is a factor on when they
flower the length of the day is a factor
and then for some plants also what we
call vernalization basically have they
have received a cold treatment in
previous months is also a factor so rye
grass is going to flower in early summer
because it's received a cold over the
winter the temperatures are just right
for flowering and the day length is just
right for flowering and that's very
predictable from one year to the next
and so that those flowers are what
you're talking about the seed heads the
brown stalks that we see there that's
the stock that once held that flower up
in the air so we do know that if we give
the turf a little more fertilizer and
while we didn't study this I would add
that if we irrigate the turf that will
help with the decomposition of those
stocks and that's what I think it is a
decomposition of those stocks more
rapidly it's not that the plant's
forming less of them and it's that with
that added water and fertility then the
microbes can break those stocks down a
little bit faster and they'll disappear
from our turf plus that's helping the
the turf density which which may also
kind of mask uh some of those now from a
scalping standpoint what we essentially
found is that if we mow the turf just a
little bit lower when we know that seed
head is about to come then essentially
what we can do is cut off or remove a
lot of those seed heads before they've
uh they've they've emerged and then
while we're dealing with a little bit of
a short term uh you know scalping
although again our turf still looked
green after we scalped it we still had
good burger we didn't have as many seed
heads afterwards and this just kind of
came about accidental you know out at
the research center mowing some things
and this observation by Ross that where
he had moaned some some grass a little
bit shorter for some other purpose that
now all of a sudden we weren't seeing as
many seed heads later on and that's what
led to the the so let's define this
scalping thing a little bit
um it stayed green so you're you
essentially violated the one-third Rule
and at least based on some of Bill's
Work and Carl's exploration of how
animals eat grass that when you violate
that one-third rule a little bit you get
a surge of growth on the other side is
that part of the two Aaron that when you
how much did you cut below the one third
if you could remember and then and then
did you notice because I know you've had
a whole series of papers where you've
you know looked at the carbon nitrogen
fluxes out of Mowing and things like
that so
um did you notice a big surge in growth
when the ryegrass was was cut back like
that
yeah I would not say that we noticed a
big surge of growth but we also weren't
you know looking for that or we weren't
you know collecting a mass um as far as
the height we used and this is all my
memory so I think it should be pretty
close I think we were mowing this area
at about a three inch mowing height
which means based on the one-third rule
when it gets four and a half inches tall
I mow it back down to three inches
um uh excuse me four inches tall I think
it's four inches tall I'm moving it back
down to three inches but what we would
do is take it from three inches down to
an inch and a half okay okay so not
enough that we're going to to low to the
ground to permanently damage the plant
but certainly we're removing uh you know
a whole lot more than what we would
normally remove and that was just enough
to to help nip off some of these seed
heads that had not emerged out of the
leaf sheets yet so so that worked but
timing mattered timing absolutely
mattered uh and but what was nice about
this is because this particular grass uh
seems to be more most focused on Bay
length from a flowering standpoint
assuming the temperatures are right and
it's been vernalized then you could kind
of time this and we we were able to find
that from uh consecutive years and two
different sites that we could
predictably uh pinpoint when that was
okay all right now listen we're past the
the 30 minute Mark Carl but and I I had
even more to chat about because this guy
is prolific forget it
um but I want to hear are there
questions or do you have any questions
because there's a lot more about this
particular thing that we could learn
from the value of just a rejuvenating
Low Mo every year on every lawn uh to
sort of stimulate it and looking at
timing so Carl what about questions any
questions yeah I just want to go a
couple comments so Ben polymer said he's
used mesotrione with decent he just
needs multiple applications and
sufficient water so that's maybe
something to consider if you're using
that
um Greg Jarvis was asking about the type
of of rolling how big it is so that
paper was I think two thousand pounds
was the entire roller it was a
lightweight roller I don't think they
filled it with water right you can buy
the ones where you fill with water so
that was pretty lightweight I think in
comparison to some other things
um uh let's see Gary was asking I think
he's looking for more poor POA control
I'm not sure but he was asking if you
can combine tenacity with certainty
um I don't know if you guys certainty is
certainty still labeled in New York
I don't think it is anymore
I don't know if it's I don't know if
certainties labeled in New York I
thought they pulled it it might not be
uh I thought they pulled it yeah but um
control there or not but uh
yeah what's your favorite post Polo
control in a lawn height Turf Aaron
um I would say I really don't recommend
one much for for lawns uh quite honestly
I'm trying to get people to focus on
typically getting a homeowner to change
some kind of behavior whether the
homeowner's mowing too short or they're
watering too much I'm trying to get them
to change those things because as
mentioned some of these products like uh
tenacity I got to be out there applying
it every 10 to 14 days and that just
doesn't work for a uh for a lawn care
company and the cost of these products
is typically much more than a typical
herbicide that might be used in a lawn
and and so I don't want to put the you
know those lawn care companies at
economic risk to go out there and put
all these expensive applications out
when I know that the homeowner really
probably won't be satisfied the results
because a lot of these products maybe
provide 30 or 40 percent boa control and
not 100 of the homeowner might be
expecting
okay Aaron thanks so much for taking the
time I really appreciate it uh I just I
know you're busy are you still you're an
administrator now right uh no I stopped
doing that a while back I did that for a
short time but uh back to doing uh Turf
full-time so uh good we're very glad to
have you that would have been that would
have been very sad if we lost you to
Administration so we're glad to have you
back
yeah
um so thank you very much for the invite
thank you hi Carl
thanks everyone uh we'll be we'll be
back again next week Thursday with the
Golf Show and uh we'll let you guys know
we'll try and get let you guys know
guests uh when we can but you know it's
always uh a little tough uh these days
to get some some people secure yeah
everybody's busy he's busy we'll uh
we'll see everybody next week thanks
Carl see Aaron
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu